Từ như chance trong nơi bộ chính quyền Mỹ đang xuất hiện những quang ngại só sẻ,
về khán năng Israel sớm chấm rất lệng bắn tại gà ra.
Một số con chức cậu cậu Mỹ vông phó thổng thống trên đi bàn và các đặc phải viên giữ kiến tới Israel
nhằm tuộc đầy trên nơi viếp duy trị thọt thọt.
Đồng thế này và năng lòng ngày Washington có thể mất vai cho chúng dân nếu chính sự tại diễn.
Sẵn sàng Israel tết tục phát hiện những tỉnh hiểu cưng sẵn,
trong khi có cuộc đàn phán với thuổi với kỳ,
về hỗ trợ tìm kiếm tý thề con tìm vẫn đàn diễn sàng.
Tại khu vực cà cà, một trong những bên trung dành trụ chốt,
cá mộ Israel vi phạm lệng bắn khi tiến hành tất của tấn công tại khá xa.
Những gì biết này là mọi bất trạng thái măng măng của họ thật hiện này,
đồng thời cho thấy bất kỳ đồng thái đơn sương nào,
cũng có thể tái đại trung đồng bao vòng sói và đổn mới.